your grandparents they created something
extraordinary they were Fearless enough
to believe that the world is so much
more vast than we could possibly imagine
what's Monarch monsters are an
inescapable reality that we must learn
to
survive you knew these things existed
this is your
legacy the world is on fire
something happened that honor didn't
want us to know
about it's a map yeah but what is it a
map
of we can do this together we can figure
it
out I'm not taking orders from Monarch
anymore time to Cowboy
Up keep moving we are looking at a wave
of Titan
events threatening the lives of 7
billion people what if the three could
save the seven
billion